I think the word vulnerability scares a
lot of people especially in business
nobody wants to be vulnerable nobody
wants to share their weaknesses why
would I do that it'll hurt my
promotability I I don't want to be
humiliated you know um so I think first
and foremost we have to Define what it
means this is why I like terms like
psychological safety or circle of safety
that we have to build Circles of safety
and I don't need to use the word
vulnerable because then I end up having
a semantic debate with someone um so
when we talk about being in a circle of
safety or feeling psychological safety
uh or being vulnerable what that means
is and I think we have to be declarative
about what it means uh by the way of
example what it means is that I can
raise my hand and say I made a mistake
or I don't understand or I don't think I
have enough training to do the job
you're asking me to do or I need help
without any fear of humiliation or
retribution in fact I can say these
things with absolute confidence that
someone will rush in to support me
whether it's my colleagues or my leader
and we've all been on a team where we
had that unfortunately we've also all
been on a team where you'll never admit
a mistake you'll never admit any Gap in
intelligence or something you don't know
you'll never admit you don't have enough
training you'll never ask for help
because it will get you humiliated or
affect your promote ability um uh and so
if we if we can talk about the fact that
we've all built like that and we'd
rather work in situations like this then
we have to reward that behavior when you
uh Express that you don't know something
you ask for help that's a good thing
also I think people make a big mistake
where uh expressing vulnerability is not
the same as being vulnerable expressing
weakness is not the same as being weak
so for example if you sat in a meeting
and you went uh I don't I don't
understand this um I need somebody to
explain this to me um I don't I don't
know this right there's no way you're
inspiring confidence in your company um
but if you simply own it like hey I
don't understand a single word of this
deck if somebody can please just explain
it to me because I'm the complete idiot
and I don't understand any of this teex
stuff that would be really helpful and
if you just say it with confidence if
you own it it's the confidence that's
inspiring not the expression of the
weakness um so I think if you're
confident in your weakness and it you
serves that example it allows others to
do the same also rewarding the behavior
in other words when somebody asks for
help recognize point it out and say Yes
more of that please because I think the
incentive structures and re structures
affect people's behavior as well